aquí nos dan un segmento jl y además un
punto acá sobre este segmento sobre el
segmento j l y además nos dan un poco
más de información nos dicen que el
segmento jk mide 7 x más 9 lo voy a
marcar aquí esto me de 7 x 9 7 x + 9 nos
dicen que jl osea todo el segmento mide
114 entonces lo voy a marcar por aquí
arriba todo esto mide 114 y finalmente
nos dicen que cae le mide 9 x + 9
entonces este segmento de acá me de 9 x
+ 9 9 x + 9 ok y a partir de esa
información nos piden encontrar acá l
osea nos piden ver cuánto vale
numéricamente 9 x + 9 afortunadamente
tenemos toda la información que
necesitamos mira nos da la longitud
total y podemos escribir esto de la
siguiente forma podemos poner a jl vale
aj l vale pero además podemos poner a jl
además de como 114
la suma de los segmentos jk y kl bueno
de sus longitudes entonces jl nos
quedaría igual a jk jk más kl más más
acá l ahora sí utilizando la información
que nos dan aquí arriba esto quiere
decir que 114-114 es igual a 7 x + 9 es
igual a 7 x + 9 más kl la longitud de kl
que serían 9 x + 9 9 x + 9 vale más a
ver ahí quedó un poco feo y 9 hasta 9 x
+ 9 muy bien ahora tenemos que recordar
nuestras habilidades algebraicas para
determinar el valor de x en esta en esta
expresión de aquí vale entonces lo que
vamos a poner es el 114 entonces 114 es
igual a voy a juntar las x en color azul
esta de acá con esta de acá
7 y 9 nos queda 16
16 x + 9 con 999 son 18 eso los voy a
poner en color rojo va entonces este 9
con este 9 nos queda 10 y 8 y ahora lo
que podemos hacer es restar 18 de ambos
lados de esta igualdad déjame hacerlo
explícitamente restamos 18 aquí
préstamos 18 acá vamos a ver cuánto nos
queda de este lado se cancela y
simplemente nos queda 16 x 16 x y del
otro lado del otro lado nos queda igual
a haber restar a 114 18 es como restarle
14 y luego 4 si le restamos 14 llegamos
a 100 si le restamos otros 4 llegamos a
96-96 bar y ahora lo que podemos hacer
es dividir entre 16 a ambos lados de
esta igualdad aquí entre 16 aquí entre
16 y por lo tanto nos quedaría nos
quedaría que lo voy a poner de este lado
x es igual a 96 entre 16 96 entre 16 lo
podríamos hacer con una división de
casita pero
66 x 66 36 llevamos 36 x 16 y 3 que
llevamos 9 ajá x es igual a 6 pero
todavía no hemos terminado lo que nos
piden determinar no es x sino kl y
entonces tenemos que recuperar que eleva
entonces kl kl es igual a 9 x + 9 es
igual a 9 por 6 9 por 6 + 9 y esto de
aquí es igual a 9 por 6 54 54 más 9 63
entonces tenemos que caer es igual a 63